ahora vamos a aprender unas cuantas
cosas acerca de los ácidos carboxílicos
ácidos
carboxílicos
y los ácidos carboxílicos tienen un
grupo carbón y lo osea el carbono con el
doble enlace con un oxígeno y también
forman parte de una cadena más grande
pero en lugar de tener un hidrógeno por
aquí como los aldehídos o tener otra
cadena de carbonos como las cetonas los
ácidos carboxílicos aquí tienen un grupo
o h y bueno puede ser que te preguntes
por qué se llaman ácidos y tal vez
concluyan que eso indica que esto es un
ácido y efectivamente esto es un ácido
pero no es cualquier ácido de hecho es
más ácido que cualquier alcohol más
ha sido
los alcoholes
y les recordemos rápidamente lo que
significa ser un nacido si lo estás
pensando en el sentido de ácidos de
louis pues en todos los ácidos
carboxílicos este oxígeno puede quitarle
su electrón al hidrógeno y entonces si
es un ácido de louis o si lo quieres
pensar en el sentido de arrhenius pues
éste también es un ácido de arrhenius
porque el ácido carboxílicos puede donar
el núcleo del hidrógeno que es un solo
protón o sea que también está donando
protones a la solución ahora la razón
por la que los ácidos carboxílicos son
más ácidos que los alcoholes es porque
una vez que el oxígeno le roba su
electrón al hidrógeno o también
podríamos decirlo como que una vez que
el ácido carboxílicos libera el protón
del hidrógeno lo que nos queda de esta
molecular está estabilizada por
resonancia y ahorita vamos a ver cómo es
la resonancia de lo que queda de este
ácido carboxílicos
vamos a empezar por desarrollar este
término aquí lo que tenemos es un
hidrógeno con un electrón y el oxígeno
tiene el otro electrón de este enlace y
digamos que tenemos a nuestro ácidos
carboxílicos en una solución de agua
tenemos un oxígeno un hidrógeno otro
hidrógeno y dos pares de electrones
ahora el oxígeno es muy electro negativo
y está abrazando muy fuerte a todos los
electrones de sus enlaces covalentes así
es que no sería nada difícil que llegara
a quedarse con este electrón del
hidrógeno y al hacer eso no sólo se está
robando un electrón sino que está
liberando un protón que es el núcleo de
este hidrógeno ahora eso generalmente
sucede al mismo tiempo que esta molécula
de agua le donne a uno de sus electrones
al núcleo del hidrógeno y una vez que
pasa esto las moléculas se verían así
tenemos nuestro carbono
enlace con el oxígeno el resto de la
cadena y luego el oxígeno con sus dos
pares de electrones originales y además
tenía este electrón desde el principio
pero ahora se acaba de quedar con este
electrón que pertenecía al hidrógeno por
acá entonces este oxígeno ahora tiene 7
electrones o sea que tiene una carga
negativa de hecho si quieres los
contamos tenemos aquí un electrón 2 3 4
5 6 7 y para que el oxígeno tenga una
carga neutral necesita únicamente 6
electrones entonces tiene una carga
negativa porque se quedó con el electrón
del hidrógeno ahora por otro lado esta
molécula de agua se quedó con el protón
del hidrógeno con el núcleo del
hidrógeno y entonces se convirtió en un
ión idron yo lo que tenemos por aquí el
oxígeno con sus dos hidrógenos
originales y un electrón por aquí
y le donó el otro electrón de este par
de electrones al núcleo del hidrógeno
entonces ahora tiene un enlace con otro
hidrógeno tiene un electrón - y por aquí
le queda otro par de electrones entonces
tiene 1 2 3 4 5 electrones así es que
tiene una carga positiva y bueno este
guión que nos queda por aquí se llama
ion carboxilasa carbó
plato
y otra vez la razón por la que los
ácidos carboxílicos son más ácidos que
los alcoholes es porque su base
conjugada o sea el ión carboxilasa está
estabilizada por la resonancia walker y
esta base conjugada es mucho más estable
por la resonancia que la base con jugada
de cualquier alcohol y ahorita vamos a
ver la otra estructura de contribución
del guión carboxilasa a ver este oxígeno
que tiene una carga negativa puede
compartir su carga negativa con esta
otra parte de la molécula lo que hace es
darle este electrón al carbono y más o
menos al mismo tiempo el carbono libera
este electrón que va a quedarse con el
oxígeno otra vez y entonces la otra
estructura de contribución de la
resonancia o sea el otro estado que
representa lo que está pasando con este
jon carboxilasa es tenemos por aquí un
carbono tenemos ahora un solo enlace con
este oxígeno que tiene sus
los pares de electrones más el electrón
que acaba de recibir ahorita del carbono
y el otro electrón que pertenecía al
oxígeno desde el principio con el que se
estaba formando este enlace doble y
entonces ahora este es el oxígeno que
tiene la carga negativa mientras que
este otro oxígeno ahora tiene un doble
enlace con este carbono
y sus otros dos pares de electrones
porque le dio uno de sus electrones al
carbono y entonces se formó el doble
enlace y por supuesto también tenemos el
resto de la cadena y bueno estos dos
diagramas de louis explican más o menos
cuál es la situación pero sabemos que en
el fondo la molécula no se encuentra ni
en este estado ni en este otro sino que
estos electrones están todo el tiempo
dando vueltas entre todos estos átomos y
estas son nada más dos formas de
representarlo
ahora para denotar que esta es una
estructura en resonancia voy a poner por
aquí unos paréntesis y repito otra vez
los ácidos carboxílicos son más ácidos
que los alcoholes porque el ión
carboxilasa o sea la base conjugada del
ácido carboxílicos el ión carboxilasa
está estabilizado por esta resonancia ok
la resonancia hace que esta molécula sea
mucho más estable
por otro lado si este grupo alquiló
resultará ser muy electro negativo
entonces estaría jalando un poco de la
carga negativa en algunos momentos estos
electrones pasarían tiempo con el resto
de la cadena y eso haría que esta
molécula fuera todavía más estable
haciendo que el ácido carboxílicos sea
todavía más ácido
como en la mayoría de las cosas que
hemos visto hay algunos ácidos
carboxílicos que no son nombrados por su
nombre sistemático y entonces pues nos
los tenemos que aprender de memoria
ahora generalmente estas moléculas que
no son nombradas de forma sistemática
son muy comunes entonces definitivamente
si vale la pena aprenderse los el primer
ácidos carboxílicos que vamos a ver el
más simple de todos su nombre se parece
muchísimo al equivalente en las zonas y
los aldehídos entonces vamos a empezar
por repasar los nombres de esas
moléculas ok tenemos por aquí un grupo
carbón hilo con una molécula de metano y
este va a ser un aldehído entonces aquí
simplemente tiene un hidrógeno esta
molécula se llama acetaldehído
por otro lado el equivalente en se torna
o sea la acetona más simple tenemos el
grupo carbón hilo con un grupo metilo y
como ésta va a ser una acetona entonces
por aquí tiene otra cadena de carbonos
que en este caso va a ser otro grupo
metilo y se llama acetona
bueno y si ahora vamos con los ácidos
carboxílicos tenemos por aquí un grupo
carbón hilo con un grupo metilo y para
que éste sea un ácido carboxílicos aquí
tiene que tener un o h y se llama ácido
acético
ha sido
es ético y bueno no es tan difícil
recordar estos nombres porque tenemos el
prefijo assets y aquí también tenemos
hacer
acepta todas estas moléculas tienen
este grupo que es un grupo carbón hilo
con un grupo metilo
y ahora vamos a ver otros dos ácidos
carboxílicos muy simples tenemos aquí un
grupo carbon hilo con su o h pero aquí
ni siquiera vamos a tener un grupo
metilo ahora vamos a tener un simple
hidrógeno y de hecho por eso podría
llegar a decirme que este es un ácido
carbólico más simple que el ácido
acético pero este se llama ácido fórmico
ácido fórmico
fórmico y el siguiente ácido
carboxílicos está muy padre porque
básicamente son dos ácidos carboxílicos
pegados aunque tenemos por aquí un
carbono enlazado con otro carbono cada
uno formando un grupo carbon hilo con su
doble enlace con otro oxígeno y para que
sea ácido carboxílicos cada uno tiene su
grupo o h porque podríamos pensar que
este es un ácido carboxílicos y este es
otro ácidos carboxílicos pero que los
enlazamos y esta molécula se llama ácido
oxálico
ha sido
zeljko en el próximo vídeo vamos a
aprender a nombrar todos los ácidos
carboxílicos de forma sistemática